m
tous
un dépôt de carburant brûle depuis ce
matin à naples déjà quatre morts et une
immense panique dans la ville
huit enfants de mère française ramener
en algérie par georgina dufoix un début
de solution pour un problème vieux de
plus de dix ans coup d'envoi aujourd'hui
en france des restaurants du coeur la
pauvreté sévit aussi aux états unis à
new york et sur quatre ne mange pas à sa
faim football 25e soirée du championnat
de france tous les résultats à la fin de
ce journal et les images de paris
saint-germain auxerre mesdames messieurs
bonsoir la panique règne ce soir à
naples où un dépôt de carburant brûle
depuis les premières heures de la
matinée
quatre personnes sont déjà mortes une
cinquième a été porté disparu
il y à de nombreux brûlé et sur place
certains témoins n'exclut pas la thèse
de l'attentât
hélène risacher l'enfer l'apocalypse
les survivants manquent de mots pour
qualifier ces flammes au milieu d'une
colonne de fumée de plusieurs centaines
de mètres de haut un premier réservoir
de carburant explosé à 5h10 ce matin et
depuis des milliers de tonnes de
carburant dans 27 cuves sont en feu la
déflagration a projeté plusieurs
personnes en l'air tué au moins deux
employés une femme et sa fille ont péri
sous les gravats de leur maison sur les
160 blessés 19 100 dans un état grave
il souffre de brûlures et de lésions aux
yeux des voyageurs d'un train circulant
près de la zone industrielle ont aussi
été touchés et les témoins sont encore
en état de choc
c'était comme une lumière de flammes des
milliers de pierres tombées de tous les
côtés j'ai cru que c'était une éruption
du vésuve les habitants des maisons
alentour se sont enfuis à naples c'est
la panique
des centaines de personnes s'agitent au
milieu les ambulances 700 pompiers de
toute la région lutte depuis maintenant
17 heures contre le feu
on craint de nouvelles explosions alors
que des canalisations cd et que d'un
portage quantité de pétrole se déverse
en mer
les causes de cet incendie ne sont pas
encore connus dans un premier temps on a
parlé d'accident impossible répliques
plusieurs techniciens du dépôt de
carburant il s'agit d'un attentat
le feu a pris dans des réservoirs pleins
après explosion
or le pétrole raffiné ne peut pas
exploser le plus le dispositif anti
incendie n'a pas fonctionné poser une
bombe dans l'installation n'est pas très
difficile avec des rondes toutes les
deux heures seulement pour les pompiers
en tout cas il s'agit d'abord d'éteindre
le feu et cela risque encore de durer
une bonne partie de la nuit en afrique
du sud c'est la violence politique qui
continue de régner winnie mandela la
femme du leader de la nc emprisonné
depuis 20 ans vient d'être expulsée de
son domicile de soweto par la police
elle est interdite de séjour dans le
district de johannesburg
et puis dans le même temps un signe que
cette violence continue de régner dans
tout le pays
à durban un jeune noir a lancé
aujourd'hui une bombe dans un autobus
six personnes ont été gravement blessées
parmi elles des noirs et des blancs
les actes de ce genre continuent de se
multiplier en afrique du sud en france
l'office du tourisme de biarritz une
nouvelle fois détruit en partie ce matin
dans un attentat commis par les
séparatistes basques français du groupe
clandestin il paraît tarak un commando
masqué a surgi dans le bâtiment il a
ordonné aux occupants de s'en aller et
il a jeté une bombe
c'est sans doute de la réponse au
jugement d'un tribunal qui vient de
condamner à cinq ans de prison ferme
un militant d'iparretarrak responsable
d'un précédent attentat commis contre le
même bâtiment qu'il y a deux ans
l'amendement tour eiffel la fameuse loi
qui va permettre en particulier
d'installer les émetteurs de la
cinquième chaîne de télévision
l'amendement tour eiffel a été adopté
définitivement ce soir par l'assemblée
nationale
auparavant le sénat avait ajouté une
disposition nouvelle un délai de vingt
jours accordés aux propriétaires des
bâtiments concernés pour négocier
l'installation des électeurs un problème
douloureux semble sur le point d'être
réglé celui des enfants nés de couples
franco algérien dont les parents se
disputent la garde
georgina dufoix le ministre des affaires
sociales vient à ce soir de rentrer
d'algérie en ramenant en france huit de
ses enfants qui pourront passer noël
avec leur mère
pour la plupart elles ne les avait pas
vus depuis plusieurs années un accord de
principe a été conclu entre paris et
alger pour établir un droit de visite
c'est un premier pas pour illustrer ce
problème voici un cas encore plus
compliqué celui de deux enfants nés de
père algérien mais qui n'ont pas été
reconnue officiellement
eh bien ils viennent de retrouver leur
mère près de bordeaux mais cette
dernière a mis huit ans pour les
récupérer josiane bouyer huit ans de
procédures d'espoirs déçus de dépression
puis d'ultimes tractations un voyage de
deux jours à tlemcen et aujourd'hui
mehdi et malika issus d'une première
union ont rejoint camille coralie les
deux dernières filles de l'oissu madame
perrier net d abu mais bien roues et là
il a vraiment les traduit pendant huit
ans on me donnait de l'espoir en me
disant rentrez ils vont rentrer telles
dates qui seront là et tout et puis
jamais ça ne s'était fait quoi jamais ça
se fait pas justice algérienne avait
tranché en faveur de martine verdier le
récent combat publiques menées par
d'autres maires et les négociations
entre les gouvernements français et
algériens ont permis de débloquer la
situation
c'est le cas des enfants issus de
couples mariés les enfants légitimes
pose toujours de graves problèmes celui
de tous les enfants naturels comme
malika et mehdi est désormais résolu
reste pour eux à vivre une nouvelle
séparation et l'écartèlement entre deux
pays
je suis là mais il faut que je reviens à
bats pour mon père et toute sa famille
qui manque une jambe indépendant avant
oui
ils revendiquent la liberté d'être de
double double nationalité français et
algériens et pour nous adultes toujours
crois que c'est un une question qui
oppose un message qui lance il faut leur
donner cette liberté coluche est aux
fourneaux depuis ce matin les
restaurants du coeur ont rouvert leurs
portes à la date prévue
grâce au concours de très nombreuses
bonnes volontés ses restaurants ouverts
dans 17 villes de france compte
distribuer bientôt vingt mille repas
quotidiens il reste deux cent mille
repas quotidiens c'est beaucoup plus
c'est bien important il reste un
problème toutefois il peut surprendre
certains de ses restaurants sont restés
vides
aujourd'hui où quasiment c'était le cas
à dijon jacques revon nous explique
pourquoi
à dijon les restaurants du coeur ont
pignon sur rue dans une impasse du
quartier jouvence un ancien café théâtre
le bâton rouge a ouvert ses portes à
l'opération lancée par coluche dans la
capitale de la bourgogne
ce sont 32 étudiants de l'école
nationale supérieure du biologie
appliquée à la nutrition et à
l'alimentation qui ont pris les choses
en main malgré une préparation sérieuse
nous avons été surpris à l'heure prévue
pour la distribution 300 paniers repas
confectionné quatre personnes seulement
sont venus
pourquoi le témoignage de l'une de ces
personnes
est-ce que vous pensez que les gens
osent venir ben certainement pas
certainement pas je vous dis moi josy
parce que je suis en deuil pendant que
je me suis dit qu'est ce que je risque
fort bitat de bas
mais ça demande une démarche personnelle
ont dit comment va-t-on être accueillis
et les certain que pour des gens qui
sont très traumatisés par la misère
parce que j'ai des gens qui ont subi un
traumatisme moral très profond mais
préfère crever train chez elle plutôt
devenus pour certains c'est sûr il faut
qu'il se fasse violence pour venir ici
cette année 106 ch écran
l'information fait sur cette opération
par les médias radio télévision presse
écrite n'est pas ici suffisante elle ne
forme pas directement ceux qui ont faim
beaucoup faute de moyens n'ont pas
l'accès aux médias
vous l'avez entendu il ya aussi la
dignité de l'homme il faut peut être
repenser le moyen de contacter ceux qui
ont faim et trouver des moyens de
distribution approprié déjà cet après
midi on va essayer de distribuer le plus
d' affiches pour que le bouche à oreille
puisse faire son effet le plus
rapidement possible on va essayer de
prendre compte avec la sta pts et ltd
plutôt parce qu'on est auto bus
dijonnais jeunesse et ça puisque ce sont
quand même des gens qui prennent
le bus et puis on va essayer de
contacter le secours populaire pour
distribuer ses paniers d'ici mardi on va
essayer d'ajuster aussi par les marchés
en distribuant directement sur place et
en incluant dans nos paniers repas des
cartons avec le plan comme vous ne
l'avez suggéré pour que les gens
puissent savoir où ça se trouve
parce que vous êtes déçu énormément
parce que travailler un mois et demi
pour aboutir à un échec comme ça le
premier show c'est pas très gai mais on
pense que ça va s'arranger pour la
semaine des initiatives analogues on en
voit apparaître beaucoup dans les pays
industriels ces pays qu'on dit riche
mais où tout le monde ne l'est pas c'est
le cas en particulier des états unis où
la pauvreté commence tout juste de
reculer avec la reprise économique il
reste qu'à new york
un quart de la population aujourd'hui a
du mal à se nourrir
la situation est pire que pendant la
grande crise des années 30
véronique bonnet à new york plus que
jamais les quartiers riches rutile d'or
et le contraste saisi dès qu'on gagne à
quelques centaines de mètres les zones
sombres de la pauvreté aujourd'hui il y
à 60000 personnes sans toit manhattan
pour un new yorkais sur 4 pour les vieux
pour les sans abri pour les femmes
seules et leurs enfants qui n'arrivent
plus à vivre des subventions publiques
la grosse pomme est devenue la cité du
désespoir est bien heureux sont ceux qui
trouvent asile dans une de ces maisons
qui les recueillent le temps de les
remettre sur pied à cela plusieurs
raisons d'abord les coupes sèches du
président reagan dans le budget social
mais aussi le déclin de l'industrie dans
les limites de la cité et l'arrivée de
nouveaux groupes d'immigrés qui rendent
plus serré la compétition pour obtenir
des jobs avant d'atterrir dans la rue ou
les abris reste encore la solution de
ces immeubles pour célibataires
complètement détériorés john mcclain 50
ans manoeuvre vis dans celui ci depuis
quatre ans et ils payent pour une
chambre un taudis 200 dollars par mois
soit 1600 francs
aurait disparu sous les eaux
voici ma chanson fais pas d'écurie non
seulement et une seule prix de
l'électricité ne fait ouverte en
profondeur
voilà parmi les new yorkais favorisé il
y a des gens souvent des travailleurs
sociaux mais aussi des bénévoles qui
refuse de façon active cette situation
ainsi dans cette église du upper west
side
tous les dimanches il cuisine puis
servent des repas aux pauvres du
quartier
ce jour là plus de 1000 déjeuners ont
été servis pour la plupart des témoins
comme pour le pasteur de cette église
la municipalité est largement
responsable de la dégradation
on voit de plus en plus de pauvres dans
la rue sans maison on dirait que c'est
le but de notre administration
peut-être même doit-on en blâmer le
maire de pousser l'epo hors de manhattan
ailleurs dans le bronx et broutent les
juges et bien sûr sans aucun plan pour
les recueillir là bas alors une voix de
plus en plus de gens des délateurs et
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart n'ont pas
d'endroit où rester longtemps
ils n'ont pas d'argent pour s'acheter à
manger selon un récent sondage du new
york times 70% des gens pensent que les
autorités municipales devrait être
quelque chose pour les pauvres et s'il
ne met pas directement en cause et coach
leur maire réélu pour la troisième fois
il se pourrait bien qu aux prochaines
élections si le problème de la pauvreté
n'était pas réglée et new yorkais le
sanctionne
il existe une autre malédiction dans les
grandes villes c'est la solitude elle
n'est pas forcément synonyme de pauvreté
mais tout le monde sait bien qu'elle ait
particulièrement pénibles pendant cette
période de noël
plusieurs associations cette année
encore essaie de faire quelque chose
pour les oubliés de la fête
voici un numéro de téléphone à paris
c'est le 42 33 81 70 c'est celui de
l'association catholique que les frères
du ciel et de la terre appelés les si
vous êtes à paris est seul pour noël ils
vous invitent à leur réveillon
et puis comme l'humour est aussi un
remède à la détresse très souvent je
vous propose maintenant une petite dose
de celui de michel boujenah ce garçon de
33 ans qui a vécu une enfance bien
difficile dans le quartier juif de tunis
est en train de conquérir bien des
coeurs l'année 85 l'a révélé au grand
public au cinéma trois hommes et un
couffin sera sans doute un des crampes
succès de cette année boujenah la
termine bien l'année 85 puisqu'il tient
en ce moment la scène de l'olympia un
reportage démissionnerait pas je ne veux
pas loin mobile moi non plus je ne pas
le voir comment on va faire la pluie
champ il m'appelle et moi style cuissots
d'accord
papa papa baba vraiment épuisée par un
parent deux heures de spectacle qui
laisse moins ouais ouais c'est crevant
c'est creux mans c'est crevant c'est
génial mais c'est crevant
n'a pas de femme savait ce qui fait la
nuit il pense on traverse un et il parle
comme si c'était enfin il fait donc à
éviter
josy garde car les charges sociales non
plus au départ oui l'algérie bowie
attention pour faire une mise au point
c'est pas il parvient à faire vous
pouvez pas savoir le pied je pense qu'on
veut pas savoir
même fatigué comme ça veut pas ça je
donne pas ma place à n'importe qui le
premier qui prend la plage une mais deux
claques
c'est tout pour des microcanaux
il faut que je sois un bon artiste du
réseau ouais et mais durée en haut de la
fiche ou c'est pas ça l'important
l'important être un bon artiste sait
faire ce qu'on aime toute sa vie et puis
on monte et puis on descend et puis on
apparaît on disparaît janvry dans sa
chambre y avait plein de plus partout
j'ai dit ça y est tu l'as tuée josiane
ya plus vous n'avez pas de la paix il
est allé s'acheter deux états il m'a dit
papa je ne présente pas de vision
hybrides dont la tunisie la famille
c'est le prétexte si tu veux c'est s'est
massé ma particularité à moins on a tous
une particularité
mais à partir de cette particulière
était là j'espère enfin en tout cas le
local à prouver je touche un public
complètement ouvert complètement
mélanger où il ya de tout il ya les gens
de chez moi évidemment il ya les autres
je vais pas dire que simplement on
s'appelle et magnifique parce que c'est
mon du magasin on rend des comptes
allons maintenant julo guillaume droits
dérivés
mais comme notre pays est bel et bien en
fait les catalans celui qui m'a enseigné
son rêve sans le savoir ces charlots
c'est à dire que envoyant charlot j'ai
appris à faire ce que j'avais envie de
faire moi mon rêve c'est d'essayer de
faire un tendre un fil entre les larmes
et le rire est de mettre les spectateurs
avec moi sur ce fil et que personne ne
tombe
je tiens tout le monde on est tous des
funambules
ah je sais pas aussi peut-être dans la
salle je sais pas ce soir elle est tout
seul pas les critiques
ban a pas moins de sept sont en crise
parce que tout le temps elle marche dans
la rue belfort oui louis son ouïe sont
les hommes de notre vie oui son
pourquoi janvier
ce fils de courrier je vous comprends
pas ces prix oui
je suis pas tout à fait mine wazemmes je
suis même pas si vous êtes là ce soir
ici vous êtes là eh bien j'espère de
tout mon coeur que tous les enfants
son art michel boujenah en tennis les
suédois confirment leur supériorité dans
la finale de la coupe davis à munich ils
ont remporté le double cet après-midi et
cette défaite allemande a été marquée
surtout par l'effondrement inattendu de
boris becker daniel lauclair
si boris becker est un champion il n'est
pas un surhomme c'est en tout cas la
morale de l'histoire
à vouloir trop lui demander le jeune
prodige allemand n'a pas supporté une
telle tension
il a craqué nerveusement mais aussi
physiquement
hedberg bien que battu hier qui est
certainement pour quelque chose dans ces
conditions son compagnon de double
andreas morère ne pouvait à lui seul
faire échec à wilander ni strub l'une
des meilleures paires du monde
en fait c'est la victoire de
l'homogénéité pas seulement double mais
de toute l'équipe suédoise qui compte
quatre joueurs dans les dix meilleurs
mondiaux
désormais l'espoir a changé de raquette
car on voit mal comment les allemands
pourrait ravir le trophée aux suédois
football les matches de la 25e journée
du championnat de france sont tout juste
de terminer honneur d'abord au champion
toute catégorie commençons par le paris
saint germain qui ce soir affronter
auxerre daniel leclercq à garnir les
tribunes du parc des princes 35000
spectateurs venus souhaiter un joyeux
noël ou paris saint germain
très entreprenant cette première période
et à l'issue de cette action très
collective un tir de safet susic qui
passe de peu à côté des buts gardés par
le gardien d'auxerre martini encore une
action dangereuse pour le paris
saint-germain corner de vermeulen
récupération robert jacques une superbe
talonnade pour dominique rocheteau et au
prix d'un arrêt réflexe de martini les
auxerrois ont pu se dégager et
finalement à la mi temps rien ne sera
marqué les deux équipes regagnaient le
vestiaire sur ce score de parité 0 à 0
changement de décor en deuxième période
c'est jeannol qui est là pour tirer ce
coup franc 20 mètres regarder une frappe
limpide pure qui va se ficher sous la
barre martigné battu 1 à 0 pour le paris
saint-germain
bon jeu seulement depuis une heure de
jeu les parisiens
décidément veulent terminer l'année en
beauté c'est ce qu'ils vont faire au
terme d'une deuxième période
extraordinaire est ici et le mark
deuxième but vous l'attribué à qui vous
voulez soit safet susic qui a tiré sur
le coteau à gomez qui a marqué ce but
contre son camp mais enfin honneur quand
même à safet susic il faut savoir que
malheureusement notre journal très tôt
ne nous permet pas de vous montrer les
deux derniers bus car le paris saint
germain est véritablement écrasé auxerre
4 à 0 avec deux nouveaux bus de
dominique rocheteau et de bâtonnier
alors ce soir il n'y avait que 7
rencontres au programme il y a eu 19
buts marqués par des victoires à
l'extérieur et vous noté en dehors de
cette belle victoire du paris
saint-germain un autre carton celui de
nantes 5 1 face à nice 2 matches nuls
dans le bas du tableau entre toulon et
toulouse et le havre à la dernière
minute que grâce à son international
marocain merrill krimo a égalisé à brest
1 but partout ce qui nous donne au
classement très rapidement le premier
est bien sûr un vaincu le paris
saint-germain 41 points 2e nantes 35
points 3e bordeaux 34 quatrième lance
35e monaco 28
un dernier mot pour vous dire qu'il y
aura les trois autres matchs demain
savoir strasbourg metz sochaux laval
nancy marseille donc on ne parle pas du
classement du bas du tableau nous y
reviendrons demain
merci daniel moi mon dernier mot c'est
pour vous parler de la météo demain une
zone nuageuse va aborder la bretagne
l'abordera d'ailleurs dès cette nuit
elle s'étendra ensuite rapidement vers
le sud et on donnera de la neige au
dessus de 16 100 m les températures cela
dit resteront encore demain douces pour
la saison
à peu près de 5 à 15 degrés pour les
maximales du nord au sud du pays
je veux dire encore que demain soir nous
avons rendez-vous à 22h05 et puis que
dans un instant nous retrouvons bien sûr
comme chaque samedi un nouvel épisode de
dynastie mais d'abord je vous rappelle
les principales nouvelles de la journée
à demain bonsoir
à naples le dépôt de carburant qui a
pris feu ce matin brûle toujours et
provoque la panique il y à déjà quatre
morts un début de solution aux problèmes
des enfants de mère française retenue en
algérie huit d'entre eux passeront noël
en france
coup d'envoi des restaurants du coeur
dans 17 villes françaises à dijon le
message n'est pas passé